la vague de froid qui sévit depuis deux
semaines commence enfin à régresser mais
le redoux ne sera effectif qu'à partir
de jeudi prochain
en attendant eh bien en attendant
prudence car l'hiver est toujours là
témoin cette image insolite c'est moi
que l'on puisse dire tourné sur le canal
saint martin à paris
emmanuel gagner jean-bernard hier un
brise glace se frayant un chemin dans
les canaux parisiens
ici au nord-est de la capitale la couche
atteint 15 cm alors pour permettre à
cette péniche de ravitailler les
parisiens en fioul domestique
on attaque la glace avec un drôle
d'attelage une barge poussé par un
moteur de 180 chevaux
autre manoeuvre à risque le passage des
écluses armée de gaffes les brigadiers
des canaux casse les blocs qui conte
ainsi la lourde mécanique
en aval le brise glace n'est pas encore
passé en attendant on répète les mêmes
gestes il faut empêcher la glace
d'abîmer les coques des bateaux des
bateaux de croisières bloqué à quai
depuis plus d'une semaine
même si sarah du si a encore quelques
jours avant que la glace disparaît
traitement
ok là on peut pas pas question de faire
de premières
les mariniers se désolent les enfants du
quartier souris dernier jeu en vogue
traversé le canal gelé à pied mais
aujourd'hui les plus téméraires ne
renouvelleront pas leur exploit glace et
celui de m c'est le terrain pour aller
chez moi quand ça ira sarthois du
collège est aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je
pense pas parce que ça n'aide pas trop
solide elle est moins dur mais je
m'accroche je n'ai pas trop loin un jeu
très dangereux est formellement interdit
cet après-midi les pigeons s'aventurer
sur la glace est encore prudemment en
quête d'un quignon de pain
voilà